i claim mars for britain you can't claim
us we live here
do you have a flag
[Music]
empress of mars we had our monk trilogy
and now we can get back to things a
little bit more
self-contained like the front end of the
series was so
i suppose the first thing that i'll
address because it got brought
up when i did my sleep no more review
this was done instead
of a potential related episode to sleep
no more mark gadis
did have plans for another story that
would play with some of the same things
as
sleep no more now i've seen a lot of
people incorrectly state that it was a
follow-up or a sequel
picking up on the ending from sleep no
more it actually wasn't the plan was
a prequel so even if he'd done it
it wouldn't have addressed that ending
so
that was never gonna get fixed even if
you don't like this episode you were not
deprived of an
actual resolution to that so that
established and set aside what did mark
gatus actually give us
a fairly bog standard pastiche of a lot
of the classic elements from doctor who
mixed with a bit of a historical setting
kind to his wheelhouse a lot of the time
i think this is probably one of the mark
gates scripts that i like
better i'm not a huge fan of a lot of
his work on this show
and i don't want to go so far as to make
a broad statement that mark gates is a
bad writer i don't think that's
true but his approach to doctor who
doesn't
gel with what i personally tend to like
about doctor who
so he and i are on different wavelengths
this one
it's decent it pulls together pretty
well i have a hard time pointing to too
many things that i feel
are concretely wrong with it or are
problems it's just it's not really much
better than oh
it's pretty good it's just kind of where
it lands for me
again not because of anything dragging
it down but more nothing
elevating it beyond that there are a
number of things that i do
like about it i'm going to highlight
those the first thing is i i'm realizing
at this point that i have
i've always liked series 10 from the
first time i saw it i still like series
10.
i am at this point a little bit
frustrated with the
recurring motif of criticism
capitalism and also colonialism now i
would actually make an argument that
those two are connected the colonial
mindset
especially the part of going to a place
that
people already are and just taking the
riches and going home
which is the entire plan for this for
this little
group of uh of explorers
uh that is very much i mean that's
rooted in colonialism but that very much
feeds into a
capitalist mindset the value of
money so even though colonialism and
capitalism aren't strictly speaking the
same thing
one does feed into the other and a lot
of our capitalistic society
was propelled by and then uh
born on the back of colonialism so
they feed into each other a lot so i
have no issue with
you know a series that has been doing
criticisms of capitalism with episodes
like thin ice
and oxygen to now pick up and decide to
poke at colonialism a little bit
actually i think that's a pretty solid
idea what i'm
frustrated by at this point is i feel
like the critiques of capitalism and
colonialism by association
are just kind of a thing the
series keeps doing as opposed to a
driving theme of the series as a whole
this is where there's like a little bit
of a clash of
intent versus format i feel like there
was an
intent to have a more unified
criticism of these sorts of aspects of
western civilization which is something
i'm totally behind
but that kind of clashed with a desire
to
have more standalone episodes for the
bulk
of this series really the even the monk
three-parter extremists
i still argue isn't really part of a
trilogy proper it
is very much a standalone piece that
sets up the next two
so this series really only has two
multi-part stories it has the monk um
i'm gonna call it a duology i'm not
gonna count extremists as
a fixed part of a trilogy but it's got
those two monk stories pyramid at the
end of the world lie of the land
and it's got the finale and even the
finale
shifts thematic gears from one to the
next
so there seems to be a desire for a more
standalone story
at the same time that it's trying to
recurringly thematically address
kind of similar issues over and over and
over again and
one of those needed to kind of get
adjusted to strengthen the other because
with the things being so standalone the
series as a whole
while critique of these things is a
recurring motif
it doesn't feel like a thematic
statement of the series
as an overall piece of entertainment
just because
well it doesn't really feel like it
comes together at the end in fact the
finale
at least my memory of the finale feels
very detached from these themes as does
the first episode for that matter
so as much as i've enjoyed
these elements recurring across the
series i feel like they should have been
pulled together into
something greater and they never were um
or at least
i don't think there i'm gonna get like
keep an eye on this for the last three
episodes
but to my memory of what those episodes
are it just doesn't really happen
but see there i am kind of going off on
thematics of the series overall instead
of really focusing in on this episode
and that's because i don't
really have all that much to say about
this episode
in and of itself i think it is a broad
not especially nuanced but decently
constructed
critique of the colonial mindset i think
it was a good inclusion to have
friday who is the ice warrior that
the these um british uh troops
have found and has led them back to mars
and that sort of their treatment of him
as an automatic
lesser even though he demonstrably has
better technology with that than them
because
he got it it was his ship that they
piloted to get to this planet he
clearly is more advanced than them but
they treat him as lesser regardless
and their assumption that he is on their
side
and their just dismissiveness of him
that's very true as an element of
colonialism and how it treated
basically any society that wasn't their
own
so that's really solid i remember
thinking on first viewing that i thought
the empress
was she lacked nuance she was a bit
one-dimensional as a
villain even taking into account the
fact that she kind of gets
talked out of war at the end but then it
occurred to me like oh wait
she's an empress this is an empire
britain was an empire these are
two imperial mindsets clashing
so it means that her behavior is also a
critique
of the imperialistic mindset clashing
against
a colonial arm of a different empire
so the fact that she is kind of
pig-headed that she is focused on this
idea of you know bringing back her
warriors and she's not really listening
to reason that actually
fits in with the overall critique of
empire that is going on in this thing
so that's something that bugged me
before that now i'm like oh no
no no that actually fits uh if i'm gonna
be nitpicky there is one thing that like
i half like and then the other half
kills it
the weapon that the ice warriors use
which kind of
compresses people i i like it in that
when it hits
it is a violently swift compression
and i like how quickly
that happens it really does feel
jolting that was a really big mistake
that they made that the
resulting sort of ball of human
bounces when it lands because i laugh
every time i see it bounce
i i i'm sorry i just do it suddenly it
goes from being this
horrific twisting of the human form to a
novelty basketball
in my head like i know the sound effect
isn't there but
my brain is is making a boing boing
sound effect whenever i see that thing
bounce
it's a shame because otherwise i think
it's a it's a pretty neat
uh idea for a weapon i also like that
there is sort of an evocation of
tomb of the cybermen mostly visually
um because the
themes that were going on in terms of
the cybermen were really a completely
different ballgame
but you know when we see the lighting up
of all these warriors in the wall that
is
very reminiscent of tombs of the
cybermen and i will always be happy for
anything that refers to that because i
love tombs of the cybermen there's a
number of others
just sort of little touches that like i
like but again none of them are enough
to like really bolster the thing overall
i like that this doctor doesn't know as
much pop culture as has frequently
happened
with other doctors like i've complained
before about how many pop culture
references say
david tennant's doctor made and so i
like in
this that bill keeps making allusions to
very famous movies like terminator and
the thing and the doctor's like well and
but then the one that he knows that he
makes his own reference to
is frozen especially for this doctor i
like the idea that the earth-based media
that he
remembers or has taken the time to get
to know is the stuff aimed at children
i i actually kind of like that in
combination with him
just not even really being aware
of the entertainment design for adults i
i don't know why i actually
really like that detail i like that
the empress turns to bill
and assumes not necessarily that bill
is an authority she doesn't address her
as if she's a queen
but that is the opinion she's going to
value
more rather than these men and i i find
that interesting there's actually a bit
of nuance to that because like
the the lazy way to do that would have
been for her to turn to bill
and address her as empress as if she
assumed but like
the empress has been watching she's she
sees these other people seem to be in
command
but she still zeroes in on bill and
still wants bill's take on what's going
on
i kind of like that the callback to
alpha centauri
is it's fine it's a little weird
um this is a classic era creature and
like
it's one of those things that i i do
like
this style of callback to classic error
stuff where
it's just kind of dropped in it's not
the basis of the whole thing but if you
know it from the original thing it's not
nice oh
cool but the thing about alex and tori
is the between the look and that voice
it stands out way more than it should
for the way that it's used it just kind
of leaves you going
what whereas you know i mean if it had
been almost literally
any other alien it wouldn't have felt as
jarring just because of that voice
and that very old-fashioned looking
effect even though they kind of tried to
hide
uh how old-school the eye was you know
with a staticky screen and all that
i still like it but and like
logistically alpha centauri's a
good pick uh to do that but it's it
it is more jarring than it should be i
don't
usually get hung up on continuity things
this did actually occur to me though and
it's one of the few times that this sort
of thing actually like stuck in my head
a little bit
because of what we know happens
later on later on in terms of linear
time earlier in the doctor's own
timeline with times that
say the second doctor has encountered
the ice warriors
the empress left a lot of people behind
she must have which is a little bit
a little bit odd um and it does feel
like it takes away
from i think what is meant to be
feel more like a a peaceful not a
triumphant too much but like a
peaceful nice resolution but if you know
other ice warrior stories it's like
you left a whole bunch of people there
why
now the use of the tardis malfunctioning
to just sort of get nardole off the
board
normally i'd complain about that and how
contrived it is to remove one of the
companions from the situation except i
actually feel like that was
perfectly paced you know that
we don't keep cutting back to him across
the whole episode we establish
that he can't get back on his own he
asked misty for help and
like fairly early into the episode she's
saying it'd be easier if i just show you
and then not coming back to it until the
very end
where we see missy in the tardis because
first of all just missing the tardis
with that look
that's good stuff but i love
what she asks the doctor the doctor
please tell me
really are you all right
just that one line and the way they look
at each other
it makes that connection between them
the history of between these two
characters
resonate so well
like that was honestly in hindsight that
was one of the things i
missed with john sims first go
at the master with the end of series
three
he just i just didn't feel the weight i
didn't feel the history
i actually felt it more uh in the end of
time parts one and two which is
one of the reasons i like john sim as
the master better
there but this like just
oh you put them in a room just the way
they
are in each other's presence so much
weight so much history oh you
feel it it's tangible like it i suppose
coming back to the colonial thing i
i can't decide it feels
slightly at issue that friday
who is the one ice warrior at this point
the most disconnected
from his society because he spelled he
spent time
you know with these humans and all that
that he kind of ends up being
the good one as he's trying to spare
the innocent lives like the doctor and
bill and the colonel
that uh the empress is happy to wipe out
and i don't
th there's something i don't know i
don't know enough to like
name it as a trope but there's something
about you know the
the one person from the other society
who
has spent the most time away from that
society is the good one
uh something feels iffy about that uh
the whole thing with the colonel
entering into the queen's service
i don't know it seems fine i i feel like
i should like it more than i do
um it's it's fine
that's kind of the episode as a whole
it's well no it's better than fine
it's pretty good it's enjoyable it's fun
it's got some specific moments i really
like
i like some of the thematics it's
playing with it just doesn't do enough
with them to really
bring it up higher in my estimation
uh i feel like you know the colonial
elements they're just there
they're well done but they're just there
i don't feel like a true
full commentary on that theme is
interwoven into the story it's just
presented
you know here are some messed up aspects
of colonialism i'm like
yeah no i agree but you know you
i would have liked to see more done with
it if we were going to bring it up but
you know
it's fine it's a perfectly fine
enjoyable little snacky episode with
just a little bit more on its mind but
it doesn't
hit my buttons enough to be elevated
into the well it's not a masterpiece but
it's so much fun
and it doesn't quite interweave its
thematics enough for me to
say under-appreciated gem it's just like
nah it's pretty good
empress of mars what was the last time
you saw it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it i've got a patreon
which is how i pay my bills and it keeps
this whole operation up and running
there are perks for every support level
but even if you're not able to do that
liking sharing subscribing they all
help me out i appreciate it greatly but
you also don't have to
because at the end of the day you're the
council i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]